on est bien peu de chose et mon amie la
rose me l'a dit ce matin
à new moore je suis
baptisée de rente ai je me suis épanoui
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre nouvel
épisode du petit émir la semaine
dernière nous avons commencé à voir le
portrait de marica afin de découvrir le
métier d'art thérapeute nous l'avions
laissée au centre et lindor de sainte
suzanne lors des répétitions de danse
avec ses élèves c'est là que nous la
retrouvons
oh
après cette séance riche en émotions
emmanuel l'une des aides
médico-psychologiques nous explique que
son travail et celui de marica je suis
aide médico psychologique ça fait à peu
près dix ans que je travaille au centre
d'éducation motrice avec mary kay se
chargent
intervient auprès des enfants
polyhandicapés donc des tout petits 2
3 à 10 ans
en fait mon métier
1 dans le relationnel
dans l'éducatif principalement avec eux
ces jeunes je connaissais pas le métier
d'art thérapeute gelé découvert en
commençant à travailler au centre
d'éducation motrice il n'est pas connue
essentiellement à la réunion et c'est un
métier qui permet aux enfants qui ont un
handicap ou en difficulté quelconque de
pouvoir se revaloriser de pouvoir
avancer et de pouvoir faire face aux
difficultés qu'ils ont et par le biais
de l'art ça peut être le dessin ça peut
être le clown ça peut être la danse
c'est le chant aussi ils peuvent
s'épanouir en fait mary kay elle est
très carré donc elle elle en demande
beaucoup en fait être quasiment
professionnels dollars c'est que nous on
met pas mais dans un sens en fait ça
nous permet aussi de se booster et puis
d'avoir énormément de peps pour les
spectacles mary kay je suis super
heureuse de travailler avec toi et de
faire cesser ateliers et j'espère qu'on
va continuer
c'est maintenant l'heure du repas un pic
dit que rapide prix en compagnie des
élèves dans les jardins du centre
l'horloge tourne il est temps pour
marika de foncer récupérer mathias au
centre masse de sainte suzanne c'est
l'occasion pour marika de nous en dire
un peu plus sur elle même et sur son
métier
- de formation je suis comédienne j'ai
fait le conservatoire et d'autres
formations et ensuite après
domaines hébergés
j'ai fait un des ud art-thérapie avec la
faculté de médecine de tours eh ben j'ai
commencé
avec des enfants déficients moteurs et
maintenant que je suis avec tout public
l'art thérapie
c'est une discipline paramédical donc
c'est déjà un métier je suis
art-thérapeute depuis 2003 et
c'est développer le potentiel artistique
personnes vers dans un but thérapeutique
donc on peut faire autant de là du chant
de l'ess des arts plastiques du théâtre
pour essayer qu'il soit mieux dans leur
peau et qu'il soit surtout
ils arrivent à s'exprimer
moi j'ai depuis tout petit je fais de la
danse j'ai fait du théâtre après au
collège au lycée et bon voilà et après
quand j'ai eu 21 ans j'ai eu une maladie
assez grave et j'ai vu l'envers du décor
c'est à dire le côté patients le côté
maladie et j'ai eu envie aussi de voilà
de redonner sa à d'autres personnes je
pense que ça vient de là aussi c'est
donnant-donnant quoi un moment donné on
dit dans notre vie dans le code le
théâtre c'est bien les arts plastiques
c'est bien mais comment leur transmettre
comment leur donner
marica arrive maintenant au centre de la
ressource où tout le monde m'attend pour
commencer les répétitions nous laissons
toute la troupe pour cette séance de
répétition et décidons d'aller
interviewer le fils de marica qui se
trouve au même moment au skate park de
saint denis afin qu'il nous livre ses
impressions
je serais content d'avoir une personne
qui comptait et faire des
animations je suis très fier du métier
de maman car pour elle c'est très
important car elle est passionnée et que
ça c'est utile pour les gens pour les
parents les sommes des gens des enfants
handicapés
et bien voilà vous en savez désormais un
peu plus sur marica et son métier d'art
thérapeute la semaine prochaine nous
vous proposons d'assister à la rencontre
entre la troupe et des musiciens
orientaux à très bientôt